six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number our next
caller is from the eight zero for area
code caller what's your name and where
are you calling from hi David
a long time first time a long time
caller first time I'm a long time caller
first time this corner that's
interesting I've never heard that before
I just have a quick question do you
think that the recent call from the left
are not really the left but people more
left-leaning for more diversity in like
our workplaces and stuff like that in
media and everything do you think that
that can come off as like an anti white
sentiment because it just seems that
like you know there was a big news story
the other day about this MTV video that
they put out about yeah like dear white
guys mm-hmm like and everything like
that this seemed it just it just came
off weird and it wasn't opening up a
conversation it was just adding more to
a more like with I guess what I'm trying
to say is like the call for diversity is
creating more divisive myth so what I'm
saying is like do you think that's a
call for anti whiteness being got it
this this like yeah yeah so I did not I
heard about the MTV ad I didn't see it
so I can't can't comment on that
specifically what you're talking about
is so yeah there's a difference between
identity politics in its destructive
form and the sort of understanding that
we do have different people in our
country and it would be great for all
groups to feel as though they're a part
of society that they're represented in
society etc I think we're dealing with
two different things yeah so number one
I've been very critical of the
destructive types of identity politics
that focus exclusively on what
categories people are in as a sort of
basis for yeah seeing the world policy
etc now somebody might hear me say that
and say well David you seem like you're
just a white guy so obviously to you
that doesn't make sense
because you've never been the victim of
that type of thing believe me before I
spoke English without an accent when I
first came to the United States as an
immigrant from Argentina I experienced
what it's like to be
the immigrant that people make fun of
because he doesn't speak English and
although I completely now am perceived
as just another white American my actual
identity is different than that so to
right off my experience I think would be
a mistake so number one from a
logistical perspective I've made it very
clear that overplaying identity politics
for the left is not only not not logical
logistically because it's not a good way
to win elections but I think it can also
be divisive the counter to that is I do
not believe the movements that claim
that white Christian men are the newly
discriminated against people in a
position that is the opposite of having
default power in the in the United
States thanks for watching this video
before you watch the next one
remember we're raising money to expand
the David Pakman show big league as well
as expand progressive activism go to
david pakman.com slash donate donations
of any size are much appreciated